so our next speaker will be Peter
originally from Germany then from uh New
York and now to sort of world Capital
London
thank you
so
good morning just about
um so this this year's joint work with
uh with Mulligan
who is sitting over there
um and to speak on Wednesday
so um
this is related to uh
to some of the previous talks to a
basketball's talk yesterday to the talk
we just heard
um but I would like to convince you that
if we step back a little bit from the
graph limit formalism and look at things
from a certain perspective
then in some sense
um
something very interesting is going on
so
if we start from the same idea as the
talk just now and that we want to
estimate something
and um suppose we have
some random structure and for now I just
assume this is a sequence I have an
infinite sequence but X in my talk here
is always some random structure and
think of it as infinitely large infinite
sequence infinite graph whatever so
now I have
um in the case where this is a sequence
and I think of this as observed data
right this is data that is coming in I
see the first n values of it I would
like to estimate some function of it
the expectation right so the kind of the
fundamental I would argue the
fundamentals theorems of estimation the
law of larger numbers and the center
limit zero so the law of large numbers
tells me if I take the sample average or
the first n values of the sequence is
IID
then that converges
to something meaningful namely I have a
consisted estimator of my of the
expected value of this function here
so it de-randomizes the limit I can
estimate the property of the underlying
distribution from there and then the
center limit theorem tells me how
quickly does that happen I mean I need
coefficiency of course right I need
moments but
morally this is what happens
so as a setup that I'm
I want to tell you about today is
um distribution of symmetry and what I
mean by that is that
my infinitely large structure here
is invariant under some group of
Transformations that activate so I have
some transformation Phi I apply it to my
structure X and that changes the
structure but it does not change its
distribution
so and that has to hold for all elements
or some group d
so and basically in short
um
the short summary of my talk is that if
we have suitable conditions on this
group here
and on the way that X and that group
interact
then first of all the group tells us how
to compute a sample average because if
this is a graph or some other structure
then I mean what is I may have not I may
not have an analog of just taking the
first n elements right I might not know
what that means so the group tells us
how to compute an average
so and versions of these results still
hold
so those averages that I compute that
way are consistent estimators of an
expectation in a certain sense and I get
a center limit zero and even higher
order results
okay
so and um
this is um
uh this is a mutilated picture there's a
there's gray here but you can't see it
oh yeah it's oh yeah right thank you so
but what we need is a DOT okay so
um let me just give you a toy example of
how this average Works in a case where
um
um where the group is so simple that
it's not actually interesting but I can
plot
so
here is a red dot think of that as a
point in the play okay and I'm going to
rotate that dot here
around the black dot that is my center
of rotation so the group I'm looking at
are rotations around the black dot the
rotations of the plane around like that
so and now I take a subset of that group
which is just the angles from zero to
some number okay I've graphed that here
as this black Arc yeah it's a little
black Arc that is the trace of my Red
Dot if I rotate by this segment here so
and now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take this integral here so I'm
going to take this here is a uniform
distribution u n is a uniform
Distribution on the set am right so the
uniform Distribution on this Arc and I'm
going to integrate against that if I the
the value of the Red Dot if I move it
along this line
so the outcome is again going to be a
point in the plane right but it is now
no longer on the arc because it's
basically the the center of mass of this
Arc so that's moved inward a little bit
okay so now it makes a set larger and
larger I take larger and larger subsets
of
the group of rotations and I can see
that as I go along the point moves
closer and closer to the origin and then
finally when I integrate over the entire
group it ends up in the origin right
so far so trivial so
the two observations that I want to make
about that is the first one is that when
I integrate where the entire group the
point I get out in the end is invariant
under the group
right the center of origin is exactly
the one point in the plane that is a
variant under rotation so rotated
nothing happens
right
so and secondly if I put a uniform
Distribution on this black circle here
so on the red not on the disk on the
remote Circle
then
this this
um Center Point here that I get out that
way is also exactly the expected value
of that
right
so there's another way that I can
characterize the uniform Distribution on
the circle namely it's exactly the one
Distribution on the circle that is
invariant under rotations
so if I put all of that together
what I have here at that at least in
this case if the distribution of X is
invariant under the group
and I average over the group
I take a point a fixed point and average
it over the group
then I compute the expectation of the
distribution
so
I can compute an expectation by a group
average
and that is what I would like to do but
in this case I could actually average
over the group and put a uniform
Distribution on it because it's compact
so in general what I'm going to do is
I'm going to look at the group and I
assume that it has our measure
yeah some group on which I can like have
something like
the measure like the back measure that I
can restrict to a uniform Distribution
on compact sets so then that X is a G
and G invariant random element of some
space on which this group Acts
and I take compact subsets A1 A2 and so
on are compact subsets of this group and
the importance of compactness is if I on
on a compact set I can normalize our
measure to a probability measure you
know I have a uniform distribution
so and then f is always a measurable
function
on MySpace here so that take can take X
as an argument and puts out a real value
and what I want to do is I want to
estimate the expectations of that f of x
so the quantity I'm going to look at is
an average like this an integral like
this I take one of these sets I take the
uniform Distribution on that set in the
group and I compute an average like this
yeah
so
and that is of course simply because
it's a uniform distribution that is
simply this integral here
so and if the group is countable then
her measure is always counting measure
or I always choose the accounting
measure and then what I get is simply
just normalized itself
and a simple example is if I take if I
go back to the sequence case right that
I had on my first slide and I said so I
X is an infinite sequence I said f as
the first coordinate function that just
extracts the first element
and a n as the permutations of the
numbers one thread
then this year is I'm permuting I'm I'm
basically so I'm this here picks out the
first entry of this permuted sequence
right and then what I get by
cancellation here these are n factorial
numbers but what I get by cancellation
is simply the sample average that I have
in the center in the basic law of large
numbers
so
but here's a slightly more interesting
example so more generally
think of this F as a function that
depends only on a small part of some
structure right so the previous slide
that was just the first entry but
basically I have some very large
structure and the function just depends
on a small part of it is like I put a
window on that structure and the
function only depends on stuff that's in
the window
so and now I've observed a larger part
of the structure as a sample
and I want to estimate this expectation
so and now think of a n as the set of
all transformations that I need if I
want to take this window on which the
function depends and I move it over the
structure part of the structure that I
have observed using Transformations yeah
let me explain this with this picture
here so if x is a random field on the
grid
yeah so on the grid at each point I have
one random variable that takes a real
value
and I would like to estimate
a function that is just the value again
at the origin first coordinate function
so here's my random grid here's my
observation window
yeah so I read out this value here and
this is a random value I want to
estimate the expectation of this so then
I kind of the straightforward window
estimator that would usually be used in
statistics is you gather points from
somewhere around that point right and
average over those so maybe over the
neighbors
one way to do that is to apply a shift
to that window and move it around
yeah an equivalent way is to keep the
window in place and shift my structure
around
so and if I write it out that way then I
get exactly this average here which in
this case takes a form I take all shifts
within some radius
and average over that
okay
so
now
it turns out that for these
um that ergotics theorists have a lot of
large numbers forever it is like this
yeah that's the point where I got
exterior for amino group actions so I
need two conditions one is I need
invariance again right and the variant
structures like invariant structures
occur everywhere at least in statistics
probability right and I mean so
exchangeable Random structures are
generated that's a kind of General name
for random structures that aren't very
some form invariant under perpetations
right and one example are exchangeable
sequences and basic statistics another
are exchangeable graphs that we talk
about at this Workshop right so graph on
graphs are exchangeable exchangeable
arrays exchangeable partitions random
measures you name it then there are
stationary sequences so stationary Degen
already refers to some form of shift
invariance right stationary sequence the
stationary random fields and so on so
and the condition on the group that I
need is amenability so what that means
is
if I take I have to be able to choose a
sequence of compact sets that I'm using
to calculate my error reviews I have to
be able to point choose that in such a
form that if I take if I apply some
transformation to one of these sets
and see how far it has moved
that that asymptotically vanishes
compared to the size of the set
yeah and I'm cutting a bit of a corner
here so this is the condition if the
group is countable if it's uncountable
you need
to take a compact set here instead of a
single element but
that's basically the idea so
I can make these sets so if I make the
set larger and larger than
asymptotically it must look as it does
so and this is a property that a group
either has or doesn't have either such
sequence exists or it doesn't exist and
the permutations groups and the shift
groups here they have these prop this
property and then many many outputs
so
now and the so yeah
so in general I mean about sort of means
so in a mineral graph
so it's
um for a graph a minimum means that
exists sort of a
subsequence which has sort of boundaries
going to zero but not necessary the
balls yeah
um it doesn't have to be boards so you
say there must exist a sequence of sets
uh yeah there must be a sequence of sets
but it doesn't have to be a nested
sequence
yeah right
okay
so and then there's this result that
exists in ergotics theory in like
unfortunately written up in a different
language so statistics has just not has
just lost track of what's going on there
and
um
um I think this is something that real
statistics should all know
um and this is if these both both of
these conditions hold and I have a first
moment
then this sample average or this group
average
converges
almost surely to the conditional
expectation given and I've written
ergotic component in blue here because I
haven't told you what that is yet
but so if you know what ergotic means in
this context I'm coming to that but if
you know what that means if if you also
assume agricity of X is a garlic then
this is just the expectation
so
this is a was in
for General amenable groups this was
proven by you know the Ninja Turtles
um
in 2001 but it's really the the outcome
like of successive generalizations for
long line of work by by many people
so and now to our result
um
I'm uh
I'm not a probabilist I'm a computer
scientist but somebody has told me if I
see a lot of large numbers I should ask
for essential difference theorem so
um
we need an additional condition to get a
central limit theorem for this we need
an additional condition which is a
mixing condition
and um so if you think above of if you
have I mean if you know mixing and time
series basically what it says if you
have a discrete time stochastic process
there's different versions of of mixing
for that but basically what they all say
is you take say the first element of
that process first entry of that process
and then you take a tail
from some element on everything past
some element now if you make the gap
between those two larger
they have to become they must become
approximately independent
the independence is measured by
basically measuring total variation
between a joint and a factorial
so and um the form of mixing that we use
here is if we look at this the values in
the sample average right it's always
also the form function or fixed function
applied to our random structure X and
then some group element
so one way to look at this is to think
of this here as as a stochastic process
indexed by the group right we get one
random scalar value for each group
element so it's kind of like a random
field on the group so and in this random
field we take two elements of this field
at two locations five five one five two
and then we compare that to the values
on some set subset Advanced group
so now we basically say if that pair if
we move that pair far enough away from
the set then they must be approximately
independent again conditional on
something
so
um
this year this conditioning makes a
condition actually considerably weaker
in general yeah
yes so so you have to measure on the
group but not the distance yeah so we
need a Distance on the group the group
has high measures so it's locally
compact second countable in housework so
it has it's metrizable yeah it is true
that we have to choose a specific metric
the mixing is not just about
materializability it needs a specific
metric but in these groups typically
there is a canonical metric yeah and
also they are locally compact so they're
kind of morally finite dimensional so
usually you don't have a lot of latitude
yeah
so
um
the reason why we have a pair here
and not just a single entry is basically
because the center limits the Earth is a
second order result
so a question yeah this
[Music]
so this I can understand a little bit so
suppose you have an infinite sequence of
exchangeable random variables so what
exactly does that condition imply I'm
assuming it's automatically satisfied
assuming finite second moments yeah let
me
um
um let me come to the so exchangeability
is a little tricky let me come to that
yeah
if you can bear with me for a few slides
yeah okay
following up on that I felt like uh your
previous examples about the
exchangeability and now you move to join
the exchangeability it's my
understanding correct no this is so what
I'm saying here is I applied to again
exchangeability I have to say more about
exchangeability yeah but
um this year it's just looking at two
real numbers that I get for two
different group elements
it's formed by two different group
elements
so but but this is the same action of
the group so I'm not you know I just
take two different permutations and see
what numbers I get
I'm not used to this notation so forgive
me the um
if V1 and V2 are nearby elements of the
group then why would ffp1x and F of c2x
be nearly independent no so that's not
what you said that's not what that means
I'm looking at the Joint distribution of
these two yes I'm asking whether this
pair
becomes nearly independent of this and
this is far away ah okay good thank you
so now that holds
then if we also have a second moment
then we can show that what we get is the
central limit theorem so the central
limit theorem for the lineage talks here
so our sample average
um the the deviation of our sample
average from
its limit
yeah that is asymptotically normal if we
end the scaling is square root of the
size of the set a app right and if you
think of the set a n as basically in the
previous example is basically the number
of things that I collect
the size of the data set that I collect
right that this is really scaling assets
so and then the asymptotic variance
looks like this
and um
the the reason why I've written out the
asymptotic variance is basically just to
show that it's it's not something
complicated it's really as as simple as
you can hold but it is random right it
is random but so it really is a
conditional Central limit theorem it is
it is random but if it is a function so
for in the ergotic case it's constant
yes yeah I'm going to comment on that on
the next slide yeah yeah so and it's
fine almost surely but of course yeah
and it is independent of the normal
yeah finite yeah so to show that it's
finite almost surely you need to mix it
but it could be zero right it can be
zero it can be degenerate
so
so basically
um for these for the sample ever it was
defined by groups we get a lot of large
numbers and if we have mixing then we
get to Center them at zero we also have
berryessin bounds which basically say
so which say how far is this site
um so how much does this site here
deviate from this side
so now
acquitticity yeah so in my my limit is
conditional on something that I call the
ergotic component and this is um based
on something that's called ergotic
decomposition and functional analysis
yeah
this is basically a generalization of
other super if you will of definite
so
um the technical the technical
definition of erodicity is that an
invariant probability distribution
so the distribution of an invariant
random structure is ergotic if it is
Trivial on the group invariants for
lsats so you take all Boreal sets that
are remain invariant under all group
elements and this measure has to have
either put Mass either zero or one or
that
so
the problem with that is if you're not
already used to it then it's a little
hard to see at first glance why that
would be a good idea to look at the
quantity like well but if you look at it
so there's a geometric interpretation of
this which is
um the set of all invariant
distributions for a given group on a
given space is convex that's like one
liner you can just check it right and
now if again if the group has high
measure the extreme points of that set
are exactly the ergotic distributions
so basically you have a convex set of
probability distributions that is also
all your invariant distributions and the
extreme points are special in some way
so and it has an integral representation
that's set so every this every
probability distribution in that set
every invariant one can be written as a
mixture of extreme points so for every P
there is some Distribution on the
extreme points
such that you can write that as a
mixture like this
so
that means in particular so or if you
think of this as
from a sampling perspective what this
says is you make a draw from this
distribution here
by selecting an extreme point at random
and then drawing your random structure
from that ergotic distribution
so this is what this is called good
States and extremely States
almost for the shifts
yeah yeah I would love to be able to
answer that in general but I can't yeah
so
um
if this distribution is ergotic then so
this is
clear that the set of invariant measures
is compact
okay so not in general so how can I then
have yeah so if it's compact yeah if we
have compactness here and that is the
case so if the group is X
continuously and the space on which it
acts as compact so that is for instance
for our binary sequence of say then it
is actually this is actually compact
this is actually Compact and then this
is Showcase the error
right then the set is a showcase Simplex
uh the set of extreme points is
obviously G Delta
and uh then by showcase theorem you get
a representation like this
the fascinating thing is that so
if you have compactness if you have
showcase theorem then it doesn't matter
what the points in that set are whether
they're probability measures or
something they're just
points at some Vector space yeah but it
turns out that if these are specifically
invariant probability measures then even
if we don't have compactness the set
this this behaves as if it was compact
yeah
because so in particular there is a
probability measure on this in
particular this probability never exists
yeah and the status matter was a set of
extreme points
so
in the case where this distribution is
where X is drawn from an organic
distribution this limit that I've
written out on the previous slides right
so f of x given the Aquatic component is
exactly just the expectation
yeah in a case where it's not ergotic
this means
this is the expectation under the
ergotic measure from which we have
actually generated X in this two-stage
process
that means if we see an instance of say
our infinitely large random graph right
then we have drawn that of an
exchangeable graph we have drawn that by
drawing a graph on it random and then
drawing for a graph from that graph on
this means our limits our estimators
recover properties of that grapher of
the graphene that is actually generated
so here are some examples of this so if
we have
the sequence indexed by natural numbers
then the invariance if the invariance is
exchangeability so permutation
invariance right then the ergotic
distributions are the IID distributions
if genetic zero right then we know for
our graphs exchangeable graphs that
those are the ergotic ones are the
graphene distribution so that's Aldous
Uber performance
they didn't formulate it like that and
this x this this is extra information
right because this doesn't give us the
representation of this
of the ergotic measures right how does
hoover X adds extra information by
saying as the erotic the ergotic
measures can be represented in this
particular Way by a function
and
um I mean this holds also for instance
for stationarity
but for stationarity in general we don't
get a limit object like that and I mean
I can't prove anything about that but
kind of just as an observation it seems
that exchangeability is special in the
sense that the existence of limit
objects is a Hallmark of exchangeability
yeah so for instance in population
genetics there's something called an
exchangeable partition that is placed in
similarly important role in population
genetics as as graphene models do in
networks and there you also have a limit
object that was um that was identified
by Kingman in the 60s that's got
paintbox distribution but if you have
exchangeability that is somehow strong
enough that's a very strong constraint
because it will grows quickly right that
that is somehow strong enough to give
you limited objects but for other groups
you don't necessarily get there that's
just I mean
yeah it's just an observation
so
um
let me get to exchangeability so here's
an example that we know X is an infinite
graph sorry sorry so sorry for the
previous slide okay I don't know like if
I'm missing something but my memory is
that when the sequence is exchangeable
then the adverted measures are the Elder
Shrine EP model and when the sequence is
in that spine sorry so we're talking
about sequences and the then the ergotic
measures also has to be distribution of
the sequences
so it wouldn't be another trainee right
yeah
graph is a ergotic
exchangeable growth but it's just the
subclass of the orgotic ones because I
like
um the sequence will need to be indexed
by two indices and then jointly
exchangeable then we get symmetry so
what you could do is you could take an
exchangeable sequence and write that
into
the random graph right just reorder it
into a graph and then indeed because the
the corresponding erotic sequences would
be IID you would get an average lady
okay yeah okay
okay so for subgraph counts
um
we have an infinite graph that's drawn
from a graph fund right then we choose
the set a n or which we average as the
permutations or the first n numbers
and um
then we'd make F the indicator function
of some sub graph say a triangle
so that the
um
let's make this one two three
so and then we can if we plug that into
Linden Strauss then we get that this
um this average here is
just the average sub graph count right
and we know then so a lineage thousand
tells us that we get convergence to the
expectation
yeah
yes but the group that I'm so here a n
is there's the set finite set that I'm
averaging over and the infinite group is
the union of that overall end
so all finitely finitely supported
permutations of the natural numbers
so and basically
where
the Martingale argument shows up in
graph limit Theory
you can replace it by this you can
replace it
and the connection to martingales is
that if you take
the set of all so if you take the set of
all Morel sets that are invariant under
the subset here
as a sigma algebra and this average is
measurable that Sigma algebra
so and then if you make these sets
larger and larger the signal algebra
becomes smaller and smaller and that is
a reverse filtration and then you can
show that if these guys are in
particular groups in their own right
then that actually this the secrets of
this average actually becomes
so wait in
so there are two places where the
reverse Nightingale shows up if you want
to show that
a sequence of graphs whereas the
subgraph counts that you have a
convergence sorry I know where you're
getting at so let me say if you want to
do calendar
you can plug this in
let us take the other discussion offline
between the two of us but let's have it
yeah
okay
so and we already know so this is just
if I apply lindstraus here I get this is
an alternative way to get the
convergence here and we of course
already know from various previous
results that there is a central limit to
Europe
right that is asymptotically normal if I
look at your previous theorem there your
your centering or your your
multiplication was by the square root of
the size of it exactly which is
humongous here exactly so there has to
be something that's why that's why I
said we have to talk about
exchangeability separately ah so it
turns out that if you have if you take
it if you have exchangeability and you
use these here as your the the groups of
the finance metric groups as your sets
that you average over then that doesn't
fit into the mixing condition
and you have to work a little extra but
I can give you a result for that and
that is with some extra work you can
show that if you have any exchangeable
random structure
anything you have some random structure
the group of finitely supported
permutations of the natural numbers X on
that structure on on that space so and
you have
um a second moment and you have a
condition here that basically says that
the function you're looking at is not
too sensitive to pairwise swaps to any
pair as well yeah
then
you get
asymptotic normality
um
just as in the previous case but the
scaling is now a square root of n
this has the one over n factorial which
is essential exactly yeah in a slightly
different place yeah exactly so this
this year is this here is just a
normalization so this is just the
normalization for the sample average
number of terms in this average right
but then the scaling for the central
limits theorem is this yeah
and then here I've actually written out
the very acid bound so the bastard line
distance between this side here and that
is why I've written the E to here on
this side right so that we're always
comparing to standard normal the Western
distance between this term and the
standard normal let's understand one
distance is
zero
sorry yeah enter could be zero that's
right it can be degenerate but then this
can't be really true
then square root of n over a times sorry
so
if it's degenerate then I have to then
have to write the error over there yeah
that's right yeah so and um
um so one thing that I just want to
briefly mention here if you can see here
if you're so if you if you think about
it making this again making this a
subgraph count for some graphing model
then we know if if it's an address I
mean we know it can be degenerate right
but we know in general if it's an
address then we're over scaling yeah
right we can do
and
um
one way to connect that to the Symmetry
is to notice that the eraserini just has
more permutation symmetries than in
general exchangeable graph right and in
addition because the entries are IID I
can take any permutations of arbitrary
entries I cannot just permute rows and
columns I can take any permutation of
the upper triagonal of the adjacency
Matrix and the number of permutations
that are permitted there or the number
of elements that I can commute is a
quadratic compared to the basic graphic
case and that's where the scattered
this might be a big question I just have
a hard time understanding what it means
to take the conditional expectation
given the ergotic component so can you
just maybe give a few words on more
intuition on that does it have anything
to do with like when you can quotient
out some group and then kind of restrict
it not the right way to think no I
wouldn't put it that way so let so if
you think about it in the case of
exchangeable graphs again right then we
know that the way that that exchangeable
any exchangeable graph is generated is
by drawing graphene at random and then
drawing from that grapher right
and what that means here is that if we
if we generate a graph that way
right I generate the graph that way I
hand it to you you compute these
averages the convergence you get is to
the expectation
under that graph line
so under kind of the true graph one that
has actually generated the graph even
though it's unknown since you're a
statistician you can think of that as
kind of a base frequencies thing so the
frequency the model your statistical
model your set of distributions that you
project as a model is always a set of
erotic measures
okay if you're a frequentist then you
assume that the true distribution is
fixed but unknown
and otherwise you put a prior on it and
mix and then you get the interior of
this corner extent yeah and you cannot
from a single even infinitely large
graph you cannot recover information
about the product right yeah
sure
okay so
um
we have some generalizations of this
that I just want to mention briefly
um one is a kind of triangular array
version of this if you will so that is
where we allowed the random structure
and the function to change
with n
as we make this happen
that is I mean you have to put bounce on
how quickly it changes but basically if
you get if you you can formulate that in
terms of this being uniformly integrable
and then you also need the mixing to
hold uniformly in some sense over n and
then these results basically still work
they become a little more technical to
write out but they basically work
yeah something like a generalized use
statistic here is not the same general
lifeview statistic as Adrian mentioned
earlier it's basically one way to write
a use statistic is by taking a function
of several arguments and then permuting
something and then there's an
asymptotically equivalent way where you
where you shift each
entry right what we're doing here is
basically instead of shifts the playing
shifts to each entry we apply a group
Elementary
it turns out that you get a version of
use statistic that is still asymptotic
proven normal
and um so and then
finally what we can do we can so we've
taken these averages over sets of
Transformations we can sub-sample that
set of transformations
and that is
um
so
um we draw some sub sample of the set a
n here that doesn't have to be uniform
it just has to be independent of x
and um it has to satisfy some I mean
basically it must not concentrate on two
smaller parts
but then you can average over the sub
sample into that and you still get a
result yeah
you can take any of these in
combinations each other still works
so let me give you like just a few
examples of what we can do with it one
is we can look at random Fields so we
have some random field that is
um
assigns to each a random real value to
each group element
and then we can so that is indexed by
the group itself Say by Rd
and then we can let the group act on
itself by shifts and that gives us
stationarity
but it could also be I mean
any group but I mean Rd is a simple
example so and then
um
if we have conditional mixing we get a
central limit theorem for that in the
case where the group is specifically ZD
um this is bullet how is the center
limits theorem for NF
then
um we can using this generalization that
I just mentioned this triangular array
version of it we can look at stochastic
block models where the number of classes
grow so the change in the distribution
is that the number of model parameters
goes up basically yeah
and um
um
and then there's um so we can also
we can also get asymptotic normality for
estimation in the current Fox Model all
right
the graphics model in the terminology of
this Workshop
um that is a little different because
the invariance in this model is not
actually simply permutation invariance
the group is is a lot larger and it's
not available
foreign
five minutes okay so then let me just
briefly mention this this is a little
tangential to everything I've discussed
here but I I just really like it
um so
um in in information Theory when you
want to just if you want to define the
entropy of of the finite alphabet
discrete time process the way you do it
is you take the first n entries of the
process The Joint distribution of that
look at the Shannon entropy of that
right that's the distribution of finite
set and an entropy of that and then you
take
the limit of that right and then the
Shannon MacMillan Brian's theorem tells
you
if your process is stationary then that
converges and if it's ergotic then it's
a constant and you use that as that con
that limiting constant as it's your
definition of entropy
and you can basically use this idea
that the picture I showed you earlier we
were shifting something around right
this idea of collecting something by
shifting something around using the
group you can use that to generalize
this notion of taking the first 10
entries and Define a generalization of
um
um of entropy for a larger class of
processes it's something that erotic
zero itself done and then lineage house
has shown that there is a generalization
of the Shannon Bremen theorem to that
basically if the group is countable and
these sets here have to kind of they
must grow quickly enough basically
sorry for that we can also get
asymptotic normality
so
to summarize
um
I have this little table here where I
basically look at higher like
increasing order results if you will
right so ergotic decomposition or other
Superior Divinity that is kind of a zero
order result it's a representation
theorem in order to get that we need the
group just we need a high measure on the
group basis
um so the condition of the distribution
is that it's invariant then for the law
of large numbers we need amiability of
the group and we need a first moment
for the center limit theorem we need
aminobility a metric as Christian
pointed out and then the second moment
and mix it
and for the berryess inbound I've
written
I've written geometry here in Gray of
course so the geometry is given by the
metric but in the very s inbound the
volume of balls and how they intersect
with these sets that we're averaging
over it appears explicitly in the Bound
in the center of ethereum it does hence
the geometry place in more explicit role
and then we need a force moment
so then
um have a couple of observations here so
one is that we've worked out a number of
examples and the one thing
worth mentioning I think is that the
asymptotic variant piece was always are
always really really clicky so usually
if you put Central limits the difference
with dependence you can get really nasty
asymptotic variances but when you have
this is something like if you have a
symmetry is present it seems they just
come out very truly yeah
so
um
then
we don't need a stable convergence
condition so if you if you have
something like if you prove Central
limit theorems for dependent structures
something like a golden Watson tree or
something then you have to make sure
that your asymptotic variance doesn't
couple with
on
with your limit variable and the reason
why we don't need that here is basically
because traditionally an ergotic
component is constant
body decomposition saves us from that
um and then I just want to mention that
there is so in a sense
what I'm telling you here is that
I mean it's it's an example of
universality flowing from Symmetry and
there's we have another example that
Morgan has another example of that so
Morgan is a follow-up paper on this
where she looks at free probability
and then basically for those of you who
know happen to know what free
probability is right she takes free
Independence generalizes that to
something like free invariance
and then you get again get a central
limit theorem and you can apply that to
random matrices yeah so universality
that you get there is a is a version of
The Beacon of law
thanks very much thank you
[Applause]
okay we're cutting it to lunch but maybe
I lasted a few questions those who want
to leave for lunch we'll just can leave
yes so what is the what are
so what are the tools that go into
proving the CLT yeah so that that it's
basically an adaptation of Stein's
method
um and the adaptation that you need I
mean there's a number of adapters but
the main adaptation that you need is
like
um you know how Stein's method works for
locally dependent variables whether
dependency neighborhood right and here
basically what we have is we take so you
look again at a single group element you
look at some ball around that right that
would be your dependency neighborhood
but it turns out that we can't get a
sharp cut off so we have short range
correlations within that ball and long
range correlations outside it and
basically you treat everything inside
that ball as if it was a dependency
neighborhood more or less and then you
control what's outside with mixing
I mean I was I was about to ask the same
question but a follow-up question if you
do that truncation usually by very scene
bound you mean you have rates of
convergence or do you mean specifically
you have a metric that you're using yeah
because you mentioned what's this
diametrics diametric not total variation
okay so because embarrassing you mean a
rate by barriers you know I mean we can
bound the up the massage diametric
between the error and the standard of
normal okay but you mentioned using this
truncation idea right usually that when
you do that you get additional log terms
but I haven't I didn't see any log terms
in your washer's time I can bound I'm um
if you're still around for a bit I'm
happy to show you the the bus are Stein
Bound for the case with mixing where
that actually because this was the only
butter slime Bond I've shown you was a
case for exchangeability which is a
little okay Twisted all right okay
thank you
I have a question also sort of on this
versa so if you were not it so once you
want to formulate a distance you I can
see where you would need a distance on
your space because otherwise your Vasa
stand distance is not even defined but
it seems that if you just want to send a
limit theorem requiring a distance the
space we're talking about is just the
real line right because we have already
mapped our function or it has already
mapped into the realignment taking
sample average we're just comparing to a
standard normal the error to a standard
normal that is where capacity distance
happens
oh I see so it's just a real life but
why do you I mean you said you need to
distance there so that's to some extent
it's counter-intuitive why would I need
a metric for Central limits yes yeah so
the message this is a metric on the
group so why do I need the way it enters
is through the mixing condition to
formulate the mixing condition to say
that set that substitutes for the tail
is far away from that pair of elements
that's how why we need the metric
foreign
[Applause]